everybody welcome to today's webinar
this is Peter Cooper from the NCBI this
webinar is called an insider's guide to
the new my new vlog Rafi and with me
today are sherry Bailey and Rhonda
Morrison cherry is going to be our
presenter today today he will be
receiving a lot of information on how to
navigate this new system but first I
would like to thank each and every one
of you for joining us and thank you for
your patience as we go through these
growing pains together as Peter has
mentioned earlier I am from NCBI user
services and I am your advocate in
providing your feedback your suggestions
and reporting any issues with that said
please take a moment to jot down the
email address to provide your
suggestions and feedback on what we're
doing right and how we can improve
let's get started for those of you who
are new to my ncbi i would like to
quickly go over the reasons why you
should get an NCBI account we have
videos on our NCBI YouTube channel and
online help manuals which provides
step-by-step directions for each of
these tools but the main reason why we
are here today is to discuss creating
and managing citations within my
bibliography as many of you are aware
one of the easiest ways to log into your
account besides using a bookmark is to
directly go to PubMed gov if you don't
already have an account go to PubMed gov
click register for an account follow the
prompts click the activation link which
is sent to your email address and now
you're ready to login we have officially
logged into my NCBI and on the dashboard
there are many different portlets such
as the ability to have your saved
searches ran automatically create
collections that you can share with
others create custom filters create bio
sketches and even see your recent
activity as long as you are logged into
your NCBI account at the time of your
searches now let's get back to my
bibliography
which is access by clicking the manage
my bibliography link once you have
citations in your my bibliography you
may see a spinning icon don't wait for
it to finish loading just go ahead and
click manage my bibliography now we're
at the my bibliography page on the upper
right hand side if you click your
username you will find your login
information your dashboard which we just
came from publications in my
bibliography which is the screen that we
are currently on
settings here's where you're able to
update your password update your email
address linked accounts like your
institutions credentials here are a
Commons HRA and Google just to name a
few you also have the ability to invite
others to manage your account and of
course log out next in the gray box you
will actually see the name listed on
your account and in this case the first
name is NCBI and the last name is user
beneath the gray box if you have an
award such as era Commons for NIH grants
or HRA grants icons will appear here
this is just another way to verify that
your award information is correctly
linked to your account all new accounts
are automatically set to private if you
wish to share your bibliography with
others you click on the make your
bibliography public link to reveal the
public URL you do have the option to
toggle the link on and off if you wish
to restrict viewings of your citations
to share or not to share is completely
under your control before we go any
further if you run into any issue the
Support Center is a click away here you
will find self-help articles as well as
the ability to contact the help desk now
let's go ahead and add a few citations
to our account the first option is from
PubMed there are numerous ways to search
PubMed for example you can run an author
search by using the author full name or
last name and initials or even a partial
title as I have entered here click
search PubMed and you will have your
results in this case is just one result
and this is the exact title I was
looking for so I will check the box and
add it to my bibliography I
then have a confirmation saying that it
was successfully added as well as my
checkbox is grayed out from here I can
repeat the process as many times as
necessary and then exit out you may also
add citations from a file the file must
be in ris format most reference managers
like refworks and endnote can convert
the citations to ris as you can see you
are given a confirmation box on how many
records have been uploaded and updated
last but not least is adding citations
manually you have the ability to add
citations of articles not appearing in
PubMed books patents software and other
types of citations as well now we have a
few citations in our bib let's manage
them first we will go over the features
of both types of accounts that they have
in common meaning that those accounts
that are linked to grant granting
agencies like Erie Commons and HRA and
those that are not in manage citations
there are two types of dropdowns the
account that is private meaning that I
have not activated my public URL which
is seen here and accounts that show the
public URL the difference is set to
public and set to private public
citations which the title implies can be
seen in the public URL and the private
label is for yep you guessed it those
that you don't want to be seen in the
and the public URL let me give an
example API who is not the author on a
manuscript but their award funded the
manuscript we use the private label
which is seen on the first citation for
their citation yes those of you
previously had an account the
private-label has taken the place of
other citations so in short the PII is
responsible for reporting the grant but
only wants to see items they are
authored in the public URL otherwise you
use the private label back to manage
citations first we have copied to a
collection this is a great option if you
wish to have separate collections to
share without sharing your entire
bibliography and you can add citations
to this collection as seen here please
note only PubMed citations can be copied
into this collection
finally you can delete citations and you
can export some or all of your citations
into our RIS file back to my bib home
page you may also at times encounter a
warning message this occurs when there's
either duplicate citations or you have a
citation that may match a citation
appearing in PubMed you have two choices
you can either hide the warning or you
can resolve them to resolve the conflict
click the conflict link determine if the
citations are the same not on the list
or save the decision for another day in
this particular case the citations are
the same just the author names are out
of order so what happens if you
accidentally dismiss the warning box or
you discover duplicate citations don't
front is the easy fix
step one is locate the duplicate
citations and jot down the pmid number
you'll need this later
step two is click Edit citation of the
manual citation a pop-up box will appear
locate the type field use the drop-down
box and select pmid next in unique ID
you're going to write down or type in
excuse me
the PM ID number you will receive a
confirmation box verifying that you have
the right citation and then you simply
click yes so we have at least one
problem solved let's move on to the
right side of the screen for filtering
and sorting citations the search box
located on the upper right with this you
are able to search by pmcid pmid article
title whole or partial author name DOI
or journal title let me repeat that
again you are able to search by pubmed
ID pubmed central ID article titles
whole or part author name DOI and
journal title you may also sort your
your bibliography by recently updated
citations meaning recently added to your
account by publication date or by author
name in descending and ascending order
so far we have reviewed what the
accounts have in common let's take a
quick look at accounts that have linked
Awards under manage citations there is
manage awards and the ability to create
a compliance report by using the manage
awards link you can quickly add awards
to multiple citations and/or multiple
awards two citations so let's see it in
action first you're going to select the
citations here and then you are going to
go to manage citation assign Awards
you'll assign the Ward's you also have
the ability to search for other Awards
if the awards are not your own
okay in this particular one we selected
two awards and the information has been
saved which is verified here and we will
close the citation window let's take a
quick look at the first citation that we
selected the count did not change
because one of the awards was the same
so instead of three
I have to meaning that I selected the
same award twice so it will
automatically collapse before we create
a compliance report let's briefly talk
about compliance I'm sure you've noticed
the boxes on the side and they also
correspond to the icons in the grey box
above the question mark means public
access is not defined the exclamation
point lets you know that the citation is
non compliant the arrow indicates that
the citation is in process and receiving
a pmcid the green checkmark indicates
that it has received a pubmed central ID
and is in compliance let's say you wish
to see citations that are in process for
example simply click on the blue arrow
located in the gray box above to display
only those citations so our grants are
attached and we're finally ready to
create a compliance report to start
we're going to select filter citations
next we're going to select the grant
select the citations go to manage
citations click compliance report fill
out the form which includes first name
middle name last name starting page if
that's what you need to put into your
report and you click download the PDF
which appears here
one of the last features that I want to
show you today is the ability to sort
all of your records by public access
which is also found in the sorting field
if you have any remaining questions
please take a moment to type them out
into the chat box because this concludes
our tour of my bibliography but I have
one last thing to show you coming soon
is a more advanced filtering which is
going to be available probably in about
two weeks or so grande holders will be
able to filter by multiple grants and
every
we'll be able to filter citations by
citation type public and private this is
my final request before we take a few
questions we need your help to make our
product better as you think of features
that you and others could benefit from
please write us I would like to thank
you again for joining me and on behalf
of the NCBI user services we look
forward to hearing from you
hi Cheri is a pretty common question I
think people have that came in fairly
early as you guys make updates to the
website to my bibliography and other my
NCBI accounts they would like to know
are their accounts and account
information automatically going to be
transferred do they need to worry about
updating their accounts every time the
user interface is changed they do not
everything should be in its proper place
even though the interface may change
another question is there a plan to make
a change in the number of items
displayed per page or is it always going
to be listed as is right now that is a
perfect suggestion using the email
that's on the screen now please suggest
it we make changes based on user needs
so there are a number of librarians on
line who do a lot of training for my bib
and sciencv
and public access compliance they want
to be able to create slide sets for
their presentations and they wanted to
know they don't have any grants is it
possible to get a fake account so that
they can actually create those slides
what would be a reasonable way to maybe
do that right into the email address
that you see there and we can check with
the development team to see what we can
do so they're interested and excited
about the changes in my bibliography and
they wanted to know are there any plans
to improve sciencv since they're
actually obviously connected stay tuned
is happening it will be coming in the
near future so there are a number of
suggestions that have come into the
questions pod which is a great idea
other people have also mentioned in that
they do some training too and have
actually validated some other features
and we will take all of those and bring
them to the team to see what they can do
there's a question here are you going to
update the my NCBI help with information
about making these citations public and
private if you go to the my bibliography
documentation the website right there it
should show all the current screenshots
that I showed you today if the citations
are appearing where the user is a PI but
not an author yes so they are on a grant
but not an author can you just go over
that one more time what to set private
and what you should say okay if the URL
is already public it's going to show
everything there so API who is not the
author on the grant what you want to do
is select those citations go to manage
citations and you want to set those cite
citations to private meaning that it
will not show in the public URL great is
there currently a limit that we know
about for the number of citations that
can be held in my actually that is a
great question
and it is part of the reason why we
update it to my bibliography 3.0 there
currently is not a limit you will just
have multiple pages that will help those
researchers that have hundreds and
hundreds of citations yes there is there
any intention to add additional features
in addition to the filter feature that
you showed for specific grants are there
other sort options or feature options
that you guys are thinking about or
would you guys consider taking in
additional sort or feature references
like for sort things like maybe most
relevant to grants and things this is
why we're asking for your feedback we
want to make this product as useable
you not just what we think that you need
this is why we're asking for feedback
let me put the address back up there
again for you we want to make this
product the best that it can be to fit
your needs so here's another question
about public and private it sounds like
something that would be good to address
not only a fake use but maybe even
undocumented on the system so one of the
librarians says this is happening to a
client of mine and IHS told him that he
needs to remove citations appearing in
his my bibliography for those which he
is not an author is that what the
private thing is supposed to do will by
identifying them as private remove them
from the citation okay it removes it not
from the citation list everything will
be there underneath the citation itself
it will say private if your pie or the
person uses the actual link that you
public URL the only thing that they're
going to see are those things that are
considered public anything with the
private label will be hidden we used to
be able to select the view citations in
PubMed this is a useful feature as
citations could then be easily sent to
EndNote or however is that a feature
that they're thinking about adding back
to my bibliography or is there another
way to do it
currently there is not another way to do
that if you could please jot that down
and stick that in our suggestions we
would greatly appreciate it so there's a
large number of site of suggestions
which is great and we will compile all
of these and send them in with sherry to
the my bibliography team one person says
hey I've got some suggestions for
sciencv too particularly about orchid
integration is that email address info
at NCBI NLM de nih.gov
also the email address that they should
send in suggestions for science CV and
even my NCBI absolutely please use this
address this is not just limited to my
bibliography you can use it for anything
dealing with my NCBI or inside
in general we'll make sure it gets to
the correct development team there are a
few additional a few only a couple of
additional questions that are very
technical in nature so we will include
those in the FAQ document so that the
answers can really be written down for
you and those will be out like Peter in
about a week or so in the on the FTP
site so thank you very very much for
participating in this particular webinar
keep tuned to additional webinars that
we're going to have throughout the rest
of the year